There was a retro challenge back in 2014 where?
Bobby sir is a challenge to do something vetro computery so I decided to convert the breadboard is an 80 on to PCBS and
Labeled it all up Astley 2014 because that was what it was about a Chinese special. Yes
Yes
Yep, okay, well one if you've seen the previous video
It's pretty much the same kind of thing you've still got the same said it processor
32 Cave Am a cave bomb
Microsoft basic on it
you communicate with it primarily over serial and
Yeah, you can run
Any any basic programs effectively?
It sounds like you've got a lot of fun in building this thing
But you go out and say just buy a raspberry pi or some kind of Arduino sector
Where's the fun in that where's the funny?
The this this is much more much more back to the votes
This is if you if he was going to build a computer back in late seventies early eighties
You would have bought the components. You would have soldered the
circuit boards together you would have built it up from scratch from there, so
It's it's more
are you not back to the past than necessarily the future like the the pie or the
Arduino so just points of some of the bits you might have to solver for the uninitiated
Yeah, actually what those disconnected
modules
Each of the chip sockets has to be soldered on to the PCB all of the header pins
ones which got discrete components like resistors and the crystals need to be soldered on and
The headers on to the backplane and other trivial stuff there was a lot to be soldered on on the back there
This is one above it
Yeah, it's not bad though your record for building one of these at the moment is an hour and a half
That's that's from from unpacking the kit getting out your soul. You know an hour and a half later. Yeah up and running
Thank you stream. What it used to be like trying to do a new program?
prior to github if he was lucky you had a
Computer where there was a magazine for it so every month you go down to the news a just get your magazine and read through
All the comments and all the listings in there
So you could actually type in the programs from scratch and the magazine finding there?
If he was a bit more niche there was a lot of male groups which was literally post off the information, so yeah
You'd receive a package in the post unpack it all and yeah, you can type in your program from there
Or you might even get floppy discs in the post?
A lot of programs can be can be adapted to run on this because if once Microsoft basic
There's a lot of basic programs out there, and yeah, it's very safe order to get those converted across
There's there's a growing community now with the RC 2014. They're also adding in their own bits of software
Like like the fact all programs from Newell's there
So yeah, which is all being shared on get help, ironically so that's best. That's the way it's done these days
That's why yes yes if you still want to do the typing code to by character
You can do the icky things which I decided to do with this was was modulized everything into its own
Individual basic component, and it all runs on a passive backplane the backplane does nothing other than join the parts together
essentially yes, yes
if you start from the left hand side
we've got the clock module so that animates the clock signal that runs the timing of everything there next let we've got cpU that's
At 80 cPU running at 7 six Megahertz on this one because that's that's what the clocks running at next to that
We've got the the bomb which has got
Microsoft basic burnt on to it after the bomb we've got 32 k of them
It is possible to double up on those if you want 64 k for him quite what you do with that amount of space
No idea
64 cases because he large what what sort you know keep on that perspective
how many how much space is a program take up today's to do say what's going on behind you oh the the
program for that is
Probably 1 K. Maybe 1 and 1/2 k yeah, it is very very small, and then only the white hand side is the
Communication that's the serial adapter. There's this one here. I've got it connected to an ftDI lead
so that that is a usb-to-serial lead because it speaks serial is there's so many things out there which also speak cereal like
Arduino is likewise beep eyes
it's it's the universal language, so
anything with a serial pork and
connecting and control it it is very very easy to get into as long as you know which end of a
Sold in iron to hold you can build one of these yeah that they are. They are quite straightforward
It's all nice and easy to solder stuff. So there's there's no
Complicated Tricky surface melting Zone Rs. All simple through-hole
So yeah, building the app is actually quite quite straightforward
as long as you can plug it into
The serial port you could to go there's a whole bunch of terminal emulation programs out there. Yeah, things like putty
or whatever term which which you're gonna use to talk through your computer serial port
Ok then you just connect to it and then you can start programming exactly yes
Yeah, as soon as you turn the power on it's it's ready to go you know 10 print computer file is called 20 Co2 10
We'd like to thank audible.com for sponsoring this episode a computer file and audible are offering our viewers. That's you guys
Free audiobook and a 30 day free trial if you go to audible.com slash computer file this link here
you'll have to use a desktop device to go up and sign up and then after that use a mobile device to view what they've
Got to offer and obviously listen to the books today. I'd like to recommend
creativity Inc by Ed Catmull Ed couples one of the cofounders of Pixar and
He talks all about how pixar go about making movies, and how he was kind of deflated after they had their first success
And that's all about him kind of reaching his goal
So he talks a little bit about one or two of the important ingredients that pixar have and of course remember
They were the ones who came out with the first feature film to be fully animated on a computer
So there's a computer file angle there. Thanks once again to audible for sponsoring this episode of competes val
Quite a tactile thing to be doing it's very very satisfied. What would you like a go?